dans trois heures je te défonce dans
deux heures ce matin je n'ai pas fait
comme il fallait
les oeufs au plat était mal fait le
compte à rebours est lâché plus qu'une
heure et je te défonce dans 30 minutes
il me choque dans le creux de l'oreille
plus que cinq minutes je monte à l'étagé
pour coucher notre fils c'est le signal
la fin du compte à rebours j'ai peur je
suis stressé vidé et en même temps
soulagée
enfin les coûts vont tomber je me
présente à lui
les bras le long du corps une claque de
claques trois claques
puis ce goût de sang dans ma bouche mais
pas de répit les coups de poing et coups
de pied
puis il s'arrête mon bourreau qui n'est
autre que le père de mon fils ne
supporte pas la vue du sang
quelle chance j'ai été une victime de
violences conjugales
comme plus de 200 mille femmes chaque
année en france
mais pourquoi elle ne part pas elle doit
aimer ça mais pourquoi elle n'appelle
pas la police la gendarmerie par onze
ans à l'eau la gendarmerie je me suis
fait battre par mon compagnon hier soir
là il est au travail
je suis seul j'ai pas le permis j'habite
un village isolé
j'ai peur et des moins mais madame s'il
est au travail il faut changer les
serrures mais bien sûr je suis bête je
vais changer les serrures comme ça quand
il rentrera du travail il se dira à elle
a changé les serrures je dois être
méchant je vais partir du coup c'est moi
qui suis partie ma travers champs va pas
bien loin
je suis donc rentrée chez moi et devinez
qui avait changé les serrures dont
compagnon bien sûr alors non les coups
je n'aime pas ça si je ne suis pas parti
c'est que l'emprise est plus fort que
tout cette peur continuelle qui
m'empêche de penser me fait vivre comme
un automate
je n'ai qu'une seule idée non pas vivre
mais ne pas mourir france pays des
droits de l'homme
oui ce n'est pas une erreur de l'homme
mais pas de la femme une femme sur dix
est victime de violence conjugale est ce
que cela veut dire qu'un homme sur dix
est violent
selon le ministère de l'intérieur 118
femmes sont mortes en 2014 soit une tous
les trois jours
voilà pourquoi j'ai décidé d'écrire ce
livre il m'a volé ma vie aux éditions xo
pour toutes les personnes qui
comprennent pas pourquoi on parte et
pour toutes les femmes qui sont qui ont
été sous emprise
alors voilà il ya quelques années je
rencontre un homme un homme charmant
mais en fait c'est lui qui nous choisit
parce que tous ces hommes là choisissent
leurs proies
au début ça se passe très bien il est
même plus que charmant mais petit à
petit va m'éloigner de mes amis ma
famille sans qu'on puisse en compte
puis finalement l'air de rien j'habite
avec lui très loin de mes amis et de ma
famille et puis nous allons avoir un
enfant et quand nous avons sept enfants
dès que je suis enceinte je deviens sa
chose je lui appartiens je suis son
objet et la violence va se déclencher
tous les jours ce fameux compte à
rebours sera quasiment tous les jours
jusqu'au jour où j'aurai la chance grâce
aux réseaux sociaux de revoir un ami
d'enfance qui nous donnera cette force
en me disant que c'est pas ça la vie
d'aller porter plainte
je vais donc trouver le courage d'aller
porter plainte au commissariat
déjà on me demande ce que je lui ai fait
on me dit que j'ai pas de sang sur moi
j'ai des bleus mais j'aurais pu les
faire tout seul donc déjà c'est pas
évident et puis on me dit qu'il va être
convoquées d'ici trois ou quatre
semaines
éventuellement je rentre chez moi avec
cette idée de me dire qu'il faut que
j'attende 3 4 semaines à vivre avec lui
qu'ils soient convoqués je me dis que
non je vais donc retiré ma plainte
heureusement tous les policiers ne sont
pas il y'en a des biens et donc celui-là
comprend que je retire ma plainte devant
la lenteur de la justice
mais il va me pousser à aller voir une
association une association contre les
victimes de violences faites aux femmes
et grâce à cette association je vais
découvrir les groupes de parole les
psychologues qui vont faire un travail
énorme avec moi et du coup je reste
quand même avec mon conjoint mais petit
à petit cette idée de le quitter va
faire son chemin
et puis six mois plus tard que j'ai
connaît cette association jeu toujours
avec mon conjoint est un matin peut-être
pour des oeufs mal fait ou une
télécommande mal rangé je pourrais pu
vous dire il tabasse mais vraiment
je suis déjà en sang il est déjà 11
heures du matin et il me promet que
l'après midi va pas être terrible
déjà quand je vois le matin je me suis
dit que l'après midi donc ce jour là
j'ai le courage d'appeler la police
et enfin c'est un flagrant délit donc il
va être arrêté parce que j'ai du sang
comme pour une fois ils peuvent
l'arrêter
donc il va être arrêté comparution
immédiate
et puis là 18 mois de prison dont 12
ferme ce qui est assez bien en matière
de violence conjugale j'ai l'impression
que la justice m'a écouté m'a entendu
mais devinez qui sort de prison où
quatre mois et demi à peine avec un
diplômé pour bonne conduite
bien sûr mon ex-compagnon quand il va
sortir de prison
je n'ai pas déménager j'habite au même
endroit où nous étions mais bien sûr pas
lui mais ça va être un harcèlement alors
seulement continuer à lui tous les jours
le soir quand je me couche quand j'ai
teint la lumière ils m'envoient des
messages
as tu te couches déjà le matin quand je
prends mon bus va me diras tu as mis ton
petit au violet et toute la journée des
centaines de messages et des centaines
d'appels où je vais porter plainte mais
ça change pas grand chose
et devant cette situation hors heures
l'association comprend qu'il ya danger
et décide de ne faire entrer dans un
nouveau programme de justice qui
s'appelle femmes en très grand danger
qui est censé nous protéger
donc je laisse tout derrière moi je
prend une valise et monfils se laisse
l'appartement les meubles et je m'enfuis
donc dans ce foyer à saint-etienne où
personne ceni ma mère mes amis n'y
absolument personne s'est enfui
d'ailleurs je dois même laissé mon
téléphone sur place pour être sûrs de ne
pas être pistés
donc je lâche tout nouvelle vie dans un
foyer avec d'autres femmes comme moi ou
on a chacune une chambre et c'est pas
évident la vie en colocation
au bout d'un mois et demi devinez qui me
retrouve bien sûr mon ex-compagnon alors
comment il a fait il a tout simplement
appelé toutes les académies scolaires de
france jusqu'à tendre tomber celle de
saint-etienne où on lui a dit mais bien
sûr monsieur il est scolarisée ici votre
fils sachant que en étant dans ce
programme
bien sûr ça n'aurait jamais dû être
divulgués c'est encore tous les
problèmes des choses qui existent et de
la mauvaise communication entre les
services
donc suite à à saint-etienne et toutes
ses plaintes que j'ai fait il va avoir
un procès en octobre 2014 il y aura un
procès où monsieur va être condamné à 15
mois ferme
quand même pour avoir tous et
harcèlement téléphonique mais on n'a pas
les preuves mais le juge estime quand
même qu'il ya quinze mois ferme
monsieur fait appel nous sommes donc en
octobre 2013 il fait appel et le
jugement sera en juin 2014
donc ce qui fait pour moi que je suis
obligé toujours de rester cacher tant
qu'il est en prison tant qu'il ya pas
une décision de justice juin 2014
la femme de l'avocate de monsieur est
malade donc il fait jouer son droit à se
faire représenter par son avocat
la juge lui dira c'est un caprice mais
c'est un droit procès traiter en urgence
en janvier 2015
mais pendant ce temps là eh ben moi et
mon fils on est toujours à saint-etienne
où on doit vivre caché et
malheureusement au bout d'un moment on
nous dit le programme s'arrête
que vaut que la justice soit finie ou
paribas il faut partir il faut partir de
ce foyer
bah merci et au revoir donc voilà j'ai
eu la chance d'avoir un ami qui m'a
hébergé en normandie où j'ai pu me
réinstaller parce que enfin c'est en
janvier 2015
enfin ce procès arrive hélas en fait
j'ai porté plainte dans plusieurs
départements
et aucune des plaintes n'a atterri au
tribunal
tout simplement parce que c'est ce qu'on
appelle des fadettes personne ne veut
payer sa dette les fadettes c'est tous
les relevés téléphoniques et aucun
département veux les payer
donc du coup j'arrive au procès entre
guillemets sans preuve juste une fois il
m'avait retaper donc il va être condamné
pour des coups et blessures mais pas
pour le harcèlement téléphonique
il va être condamné à 700 euros d'amendé
à l'état et je n'aurais pas mis un euro
symbolique que j'ai demandé mais bien
sûr monsieur ça lui a pas plu donc il se
pourvoit en cassation
on attend toujours la cassation et donc
voilà donc nous sommes en janvier 2015
j'arrive en normandie et c'est quand
même encore compliqué et là j'ai la
chance qu'on propose d'écrire un livre
donc je dis oui tout de suite ce livre
sortira au moins d'octobre
mais forcément ça n'a pas plu à mon ex
compagnon qui pendant il est sorti le
1er octobre et je n'ai pu réintégrer mon
appartement qu'à la mi novembre
parce que forcément là la police la
justice s'est dit s'il lui arrive
quelque chose là on sera mal vu que
médiatiquement a commencé à être connu
et chance j'ai été entendu par le juge
au bout de cinq mois alors que
d'habitude c'est un an
ça c'est les effets médiatiques donc
voilà on est toujours dans l'attenté
d'un procès et ça c'est terrible depuis
toutes ces années
donc là aujourd'hui voilà j'ai malgré
mon livre malgré tout ça la vie elle est
encore compliqué et c'est pour ça je
voulais vous dire aujourd'hui vous avez
tous forcément tous autour de vous une
femme victime de violence conjugale ou
un homme ça arrive aussi aux noix aux
hommes
on en parle beaucoup moins j'ai envie de
dire regardez vraiment autour de vous et
et 17 femmes et ce n'est pas en la
prenant et en la faisant on lui
demandant de partir de force non il va
falloir parler avec elle
ou peut-être l'emmener chez un
psychologue chez un médecin ou faire
appel à une association qui vous aidera
mais ne restez pas sans rien faire parce
que aujourd'hui la violence conjugale
est la plus grande cause de mortalité
pour les femmes dans le monde
voilà merci de m'avoir écouté